so I think we should probably get into
some of the details of why I think
um we're confused about what
Consciousness is yes but just to finish
this point
I think
that we don't actually have any evidence
that consciousness
is complex that it comes out of complex
processing that it's required for
complex processing and I think we've
made this anthropomorphic mistake
because we are conscious and it's very
hard to to get evidence
um it's one of the things that makes
Consciousness unique and mysterious and
why I'm fascinated with it is it's the
one thing in nature that we can't get
conclusive evidence of from the outside
we can buy analogy you know you're
behaving
basically the same way I behave more or
less
um you talk about your conscious
experiences and therefore I just
extrapolate from that that you're having
a felt experience in the way I am and
and we can do that throughout nature
well there's no physical evidence
there's nothing we can observe from the
outside that will give us conclusive
proof that Consciousness is there and so
I think we've made this leap to
because we're conscious and because
we're unique and special and
um complex and intelligent in the way
that we are and because we don't have an
intuition that anything else is
conscious or we have no feedback about
it we've made this assumption that
Consciousness that those things aren't
conscious and felt experience does not
exist out there in in other atoms and
and forms of life even but especially
not inanimate objects
um and therefore consciousness
is somehow tied to these other things
that make us unique that consciousness
arises when there is this complex
processing when there is and there's we
can talk about the evolution argument
too which I think is super interesting
to get into and I'm hoping to talk to
Richard Dawkins
um about this verse about consciousness
he's not interested
he's not interested in actually the
conversation I would have with him would
be very brief because he's he's just not
that interested in this topic but let's
go back to the Richard Dawkins piece
because there's I feel like there's a
lot to talk about here in terms of our
intuitions about Consciousness what it's
doing why in my book and you know
everywhere I talk about Consciousness I
bring it back to these two questions
that I think are at the heart of our
intuitions about Consciousness and so
your questions about whether human
beings are unique and special and all of
that
um I think are interesting questions and
something we could talk about I see them
as separate questions from the
Consciousness question so you see
Consciousness as giving a felt
experience to our uniqueness as opposed
to the uniqueness giving birth to gosh
yes and that potentially there is felt
experience even though it sounds crazy
even to me that there is felt experience
in all matter and at this point in my
thinking and after a few conversations
with some physicists I think if
conscious is fundamental the only thing
that actually makes sense is that it is
part of the most fundamental
that space-time and everything else
emerges out of out of Consciousness felt
experience is is just part of the fabric
of reality so is it possible to Intuit
this can we start by thinking about dogs
and cats go to the plants and then going
all the way to matter or is this going
to be like modern physics where it's
just going to be impossible to even uh
in in the the through our reason alone
like we're gonna have to have tools of
some kind I think it'll be a little bit
of both I mean I think the science has a
very long way to go and the truth is I
don't even think we can get to the
science yet because we have to do this
work and this is why I'm so passionate
about this work
um and it's really it's really taking
hold I mean there are scientists
neuroscientists and physicists
interested in Consciousness and kind of
having gotten over the initial
Obstacle of
wrestling with these intuitions so that
it's now being talked about in a serious
way which was the first huge hurdle but
I think a lot more of that has to happen
a lot more of the intuition breaking
from the science we already have I mean
I think we almost need to catch our
intuitions up to what we we already know
um and then continue to break through
these intuitions systematically so that
we can really think more clearly about
Consciousness
um there are a couple of scientists now
working on theories of Consciousness
which
do go they don't quite go to the
fundamental level but they go extremely
deep
um so that something like an electron
might be conscious under their Theory
this is um
integrated information Theory IIT with
Christoph Coke and Julio tanoni
um I've spoken to both of them I spoke
to Christoph coke uh once or twice for
for this project I'm working on now
um what they're working on is incredibly
interesting to me and I think very
important work
um however
I think they are also really led by some
false intuitions about self and Free
Will and I think that will be a limit to
their work so we can get into that but
um let's go
it's awesome which is that
what they're working on I think is the
most important next step forward which
is just even being open to the fact that
Consciousness goes as deep as particles
and being rigorous but even their Theory
isn't going as deep as I think we need
to go
um and it's hard to say how we could
actually study this scientifically but
that's part of the reason why I'm such a
supporter of IIT and why I'm so
interested in what they're doing even
though I think they're wrong
um is because they're they're opening
this path and I think they're getting
more people interested and I think
um yeah it'll be it'll be it's hard for
me to imagine what the science will
actually look like but okay so your
Intuition or at least the direction
which you're pushing is that
consciousness
is the only fundamental thing in the
universe that
everything else like time all those
kinds of things emerge from that
I will say that
what I believe at this point I I've been
saying 50 50 for a long time I'd say now
it's like 51.49
in terms of Consciousness being emergent
versus fundamental so I I'm not
convinced of this at all I'm not
convinced that Consciousness is
fundamental what I think is there are
very good reasons to think it could be
and
essentially all of science up to this
point has
been led by the other assumption by the
first assumption that Consciousness
arises at some point namely in brains
and that's where all the science has
gone and I think that's wonderful and I
think it should keep on going and I
actually think that was a more important
place to start but I think there's a
possibility that the correct assumption
is that it's fundamental and so that's
the science I support that's the thing I
spend a lot of my time thinking about
and talking to scientists and
philosophers about and so I I shouldn't
give the idea that I actually have
crossed over into believing this is the
case but it is
it's the Assumption I follow in my work
at this point it's a possibility an
understudied possibility so it deserves
serious reverse attention and there are
good reasons to start with that
assumption versus the other that I think
we're just now starting to realize so
just to clarify when we're talking about
Consciousness we're talking about the
hard problem of Consciousness that it
feels like something to
you know there's a subjective experience
do we
you know if Consciousness permeates all
matter is fundamental
is that going to be somehow
is our current intuition about
Consciousness like
the very tiny subset of what
cautiousness actually is so like we have
our intuitions about personal
experiences like what it feels like what
it takes to eat a cookie or something
like that
uh but
that seems like a very specific
implementation of Consciousness in an
organism so how can we even reason about
something that's if Consciousness is
fundamental how can we reason about that
like I'm not sure I'm understanding the
connection between those two things but
when you think about what it's like to
be a plant to experience a thing okay we
can kind of get that we can kind of
understand that there are a lot of
places we could go with this one is
there's actually work being done by
people like David Eagleman he's a
neuroscientist I don't know if you know
him you should talk to him for your
podcast if you haven't he's wonderful
great science Communicator he's someone
I interviewed for my my current project
too
um so he he's done this actually okay
there are many places we can go one is
he does work with sensory addition
sensory substitution and this is
going in some very interest interesting
directions and and maybe partly answers
your question which is giving humans
qualia sensory experiences that we're
not wired for that human beings have
never had before
you let me know what you're most
interested in hearing about but we could
talk about things like the brain Port
there was actually a study done I just
talked to one of the participants in the
study where they were seeing if they
could give human beings an experience of
magnetic north so other animals have
this
um
this sense that that we don't have where
they can feel intuitively the way that
our eyes work to give us an intuitive
sense of our environment we don't have
to translate the information coming in
through our eyes we just have a map of
the external world and we can navigate
it so many animals use a sense of
magnetic north to to get around and it's
an intuitive sense
so I spoke to someone who was in this
part of this experiment
um and it was fascinating to hear him
acquire a sense not only that he had
never had but that no human being had
ever had so when I asked him to describe
the experience
it was challenging for him and
understandably so because it would be
like you describing sight to someone
who's never seen
but this is clearly possible and
scientists like David Eagleman and
others are working on these and so I do
think it's possible that this line that
this
these scientific advancements may
actually start to dovetail with
the Consciousness research in terms of
being able to
experience things we've never
experienced before but I do think that
at some level yes we're limited as human
beings
we may be able to find some proof or
enough proof to at least
assume that Consciousness is fundamental
or you know who knows one day actually
believe that that's the correct
scientific view of things and not really
be able to get our minds around that or
to understand what it means and and
certainly not
to know what it feels like I mean we
can't we don't even know what it feels
like to be other creatures maybe we'll
be what it's like to be you
yeah I mean I mean that's I guess that's
what empathy is about that's why I tried
to exercise is try to imagine what it's
like to be other people and then you
you're doing that even farther
but perhaps perhaps we can do that thing
more rigorously by connecting different
sensory mechanisms to the brain to do
that for all kinds of organisms on Earth
but they're similar to Austin scale and
the time at which they function to time
scale and the spatial scale perhaps it's
much more difficult to do for electrons
and so on some of the intuitions I
talked about I mean I just kind of I I'm
taking them for granted that you and
everyone knows what I'm talking about
but in terms of the science in terms of
the studies
um understanding things like binding
processes understanding just a little
bit about how the brain works and as far
as we understand and then there's just a
ton of evidence now to support that our
conscious experience is at the tail end
of a lot of brain processing
yeah so it's just a little bit I mean I
give in the example in my book I I talk
about tennis and The Binding of the
sights and sounds and felt experience of
hitting a tennis ball which in the world
are happening at different times the the
rates
um it takes the sound waves and the
light waves and the the felt sensation
to travel to my brain are different that
there are these binding processes
that happen
prior to the conscious experience that
were essentially delivered to us by by
the brain
um and so we can get we can get back in
into this I can answer your your bigger
question first but I I feel like for for
a lot of people
to understand some of the science that
already
is shattering some of our intuitions
about the role Consciousness plays I
think is a helpful in terms of being
able to be open to thinking about these
other ideas let's go there where the
heck does Consciousness happen in what
we understand about the brain timing
wise
uh I mean this connects to the conscious
will to our experience of free will yeah
there is this period of time and it's
depending on the situation and the
behavior
um it can be anywhere from it's
essentially half a second there's 200
milliseconds I actually don't know I was
going to compare it to the timing of
thinking film and sound I don't know if
you know this yeah and I know this very
well you do the the the film and sound
yeah like yes what how the time how the
timing has to work so that we conscious
so that our experiences of it happening
at the same time
let me just let me just sit sit in the
in the Silence of it there's been so
much pain on this one point
I have no idea so I mean I yeah I did a
lot of algorithms on automatic
synchronization of audio and video and
all these kinds of things no I know this
well uh there's a lot of Science and
there's a lot of differences but it's
about
and people claim it's about 100
milliseconds you can't tell the
difference but it's much more like 30 to
50 milliseconds okay and it it Dr you
can go nuts trying to see if something
is in sync or not yes is it in sync or
not well also am I out of sync right now
brain is constantly making adjustments
yeah and so it can shift for you while
you're doing that which is probably part
of the thing that's driving you crazy
um okay so I'll start with binding
processes and then I'll just give a
couple examples
um so yes there's this window
um where your brain is
essentially putting all the information
together to deliver you a present moment
experience that is most useful for you
to navigate the world
um
so as I said and you know I use this
example of tennis in my book so the
sights and sounds are coming at us at
different rates
um it takes longer for a sensation in my
hand when I hit the ball with the racket
to travel to my brain than it does for
the light waves to hit my retina and get
processed by the brain so all these
these signals are coming in at different
times our brains go through this process
of binding to basically weave it all
together so that our our conscious
experience of that is of seeing hearing
and feeling the ball hit the racket all
at the same time that's obviously most
useful to us
binding is is mostly about timing it can
be about other things but I was just
talking to David Eagleman who was
talking about a very simple experiment
actually and this kind of shows how your
brain is basically always interacting
with the outside world and always making
adjustments to make its best guess about
the most useful present moment
experience to deliver
so this is a very simple experiment this
is from many many years ago
um and David David Eagleman was was
involved in this research where they had
participants hit a button and that
button caused a flash of light and
so our brains through binding the brain
it notices is is able to
kind of calibrate the experience you
have because the brain is aware that it
is its own hand that is causing the
light to flash that there's this cause
and effect going on and so you
have this experience of pushing the
button that causes the flash of Light
which is true and the light flashes
you can start to introduce longer pauses
starting with 20 milliseconds 30
milliseconds going up to I think 100
maybe even 200 milliseconds where if you
do it gradually since your brain is
making the adjustment
um you can introduce a delay I think
it's up to 200 milliseconds if you do it
gradually you will still have the
experience even though there's now a
delay between when you hit the button
and the light flashes you will still
have the exact same experience you had
initially which is that the light
flashes right when you push the button
in your experience nothing is changing
but then
so they they gradually give a delay
you've acclimated to that because it was
done gradually if they then go back to
the original instantaneous Flash
your brain doesn't have time to make the
adjustment and you have the experience
that the light flashed before you hit
the button and that is your true
experience it's not like you're confused
but that is your brain didn't have time
to to make that adjustment you think
you're in the same environment you're
pushing the button it makes the light
flash it's kind of
calibrating all the time but then the
the participants are suddenly saying oh
wait that was so weird the light flashed
before I hit the button
and so these types that's crazy they
built a
um Rochambeau rock paper scissors
computer game that was unbeatable based
on this glitch that you can present in
in binding by training someone if you
introduce a delay slowly enough then the
computer can get the information
before it responds but you still have
the experience that you're both
throwing out your rock or paper scissors
at the same time but in actuality the
computer
saw your choice
before it makes its choice and it's in
this window of milliseconds where you
don't notice it
so that starts to help you build up an
intuition that this conscious experience
is an illusion constructed by the brain
after uh conscious will conscious will
yeah and and just in general that that
Consciousness is not the thing that we
feel it is which is driving the behavior
that is actually at the tail end of it
and so a lot of decision-making
processes and they're studies that are
more controversial and I don't usually
like to cite them although if you want
to talk about them we can they're super
interesting and into intuition
shattering but they're they're now
studies specifically about free will to
see if there are markers at the level of
the brain they can see what decision
you're going to make and when you make
that decision and I think this the
Neuroscience inevitably is just going to
get better and so
part of the reason I'm so passionate
about this I mean there's there's the
science and there's just the Curiosity
that that drives me of wanting to
understand how the universe works but I
actually see a lot of the Neuroscience
presenting us with truths that are going
to be difficult for us to accept
and I actually think there are really
positive ways to view these truths that
we're uncovering and even though they
can be initially kind of jarring and
even destabilizing and creepy I think
ultimately
there's actually a lot
it can have a positive effect on human
psychology and a whole range of things
that I and others have have experienced
and that I think it's important for us
to talk about because
you can't hide from the truth especially
in science right like it just it will
reveal itself and if this is true I
think not only
for better understanding the universe
than nature which is kind of my my
primary passion
um it's important for us to
absorb these facts and realize that they
don't it doesn't necessarily take away
the things from us that we fear
um I you know I've heard people say this
is talked about the common common point
to make or question to ask a scientist
can you still
you know enjoy chocolate if you're a
molecular biologist and
um is in a molecular biologist that
would be the one who would understand
how we experience chocolate
yeah but anyway the point stance if
you're focused on the the details of the
you know the underlying nature of
reality does that take
the joy and the pleasure and for lack of
a better word spirituality out of our
experience as human beings and I
actually think
um for these Illusions like Free Will
and self the reverse is true I actually
think they can give us
their reasons and bases for
feeling more connected to each other and
to the universe for Spiritual
experiences for
um
even just on a more basic level for
increasing our well-being just in terms
of our psychology of lowering rates of
depression and anxiety and
um actually I think these realizations
can be extremely helpful to people
well it's like uh realizing that the
universe doesn't rotate around Earth
that the Earth is not the center the
universe is a really challenging thought
well people were worried about how that
would affect society well yes that's
like long term but short-term I bet you
the number of
people who had an accidental crisis as
it got integrated into society that
thought is huge it's like um
it's a hard one and you're saying but it
can't but it's also a source of awe and
I mean so many people now use that fact
to
inspire a positive
um response to inspire creativity and
curiosity and awe and all of these
things that are so
um useful for human well-being where's
the source of meaning
when you're not the center of the
universe when the you doesn't even exist
that even you this the the sense of self
and this
and the sense of decision making is an
illusion
the truth is that for the most part the
sense of self is kind of at the core of
human suffering because it feels as if
we are separate from the rest of nature
we're separate from each other we're
separate from
um you know the the illusion that I that
I referenced a feeling like you know we
have these thoughts that are brain based
thoughts but then the eye swoops in to
make a decision
um in some sense it goes so deep that
it's as if the eye is separate from the
physical world
and that separation
um plays a part in depression plays a
part in anxiety
um even plays a part in addiction so at
the level of the brain
um I think stop me if I'm repeating
myself but we started talking about the
default mode Network
um and so we actually know that when the
default mode network is quieted down
when people lose a sense of self in
meditation and on psychedelic drugs in
in therapy
there is a feeling that people describe
of
an extremely positive feeling of being
connected to the rest of Nature and so
that's a piece of it that I think if you
haven't had the experience
um you wouldn't necessarily know that
would be a part of it
but truly having that Insight that
you're not the self you feel you are
immediately your experiences are
embedded in the universe and you are a
piece of everything and you see that
everything is interconnected and so
rather than feeling like a lonely eye in
this bigger Universe there's a sense of
being a part of something larger than
yourself and this is intrinsically
positive for human beings
um and even just in our everyday lives
and choices and what we do for work
feeling part of something larger than
yourself is the way people describe
spiritual experiences in the way
um many positive psychological states
are framed and so there there's that
piece of it there is something there's a
one giant hug with the universe uh
everything in it but there is some sense
in which
we attach the search for meaning
with um the eye
with the ego
and uh you you it could almost seem like
life is meaningless our existence our
eye my existence is meaningless it
doesn't kind of go there under any world
view right really right
um and the truth is
we want to find
a truth
out of that downward spiral and not
a story that
we have to tell ourselves that isn't
true and the fact is we have these facts
available to us that
in with the right Framing and the right
context
um
looking at the truth actually provides
us with that psychological feeling we're
searching for and I think that's
important to point out I think humans
are
fascinatingly good at finding Beauty In
Truth No matter how painful the truth is
so yes I totally agree yes but in this
case
I think there are
the concerns are legitimate concerns and
I have them myself for how people
respond I've actually had people tell me
they had to stop reading my book halfway
through
because
the parts on Free Will were so upsetting
to them
and this is something I think about a
lot because of that
kind of breaks my heart
um I don't
because I see this potential for these
realizations bringing
levels of well-being that many people
don't have access to
um I think it's important to talk about
them in ways that override what can be
an initial
um
fear or kind of spooky spooky quality
that can come out of these realizations
so at the end of that Journey there's
there's a Clarity and an appreciation of
beauty that if you just write it out by
the way if you want to read I'm saying I
just gotten through
the boy the the four books if you want
to read upsetting so my my audible is
hilarious so there's conscious in it
and then so your book and then and then
it has the rise and fall of the Third
Reich
uh
bloodlands but by Timothy Snyder
probably the most upsetting book I've
ever read if you wanna because it's not
just Stalin or Hitler it's Stalin and
Hitler it's the worst the worst hits the
opposite of the best hits It's really
really well written really difficult
um I read uh sojinitzen's
um go like archipelago and what else red
famine which is uh
um and applebum does that does that hurt
yeah anyway so those are truly upsetting
and that's yeah and those are a lot of
times the results of
um hiding the truth versus pursuing the
truth so truth in the short term might
hurt but it did ultimately uh sets us
free I believe that and I also think
um whatever the truth is we have to find
a way to
maintain civil society and love and all
the things that are important to us